this is the World Wide Web a giant
decentralized network connecting
billions of people across the world the
source of much of the world's freest and
most innovative content shaped and
improved by the world's freest and most
innovative minds yet designed and
controlled by no single person company
or government the internet functions by
sending small clusters of information
called data packets from one computer to
another this data packet transmission is
how you are able to read online
newspapers download songs or watch
online videos internet service providers
or ISPs own the networks of wire and
cable through which these packets travel
and for the use of these travel ways the
companies that own them charge users a
fee usually a flat monthly fee in some
countries like China and Pakistan the
government puts up blocks along these
travel ways because some of the packets
have information that officials don't
want people to see but in the US this
interconnected system has stayed very
open and free because the government has
stayed hands-off and the companies have
incentive to cooperate with each other
so that each of their networks keeps the
data flowing as quickly and smoothly as
possible
but now that freedom we enjoy in the
u.s. is threatened thanks to the efforts
of the Federal Communications Commission
to impose so-called net neutrality rules
net neutrality advocates claim that
without their rules
ISPs will impede access to content
provided by companies they don't like or
view as competition net neutrality would
correct this situation by forcing ISPs
to be neutral by offering equal
accessibility to all online content but
the problem is this nightmare scenario
net neutrality advocate deposit has
never actually happened if AT&T DSL
blocked your access to Google because
they wanted you to use Yahoo what would
you do probably cancel your plan and go
to a provider that gives you easy access
to your favorite sites neutrality is
what most customers want
which is exactly why ISPs have stayed
neutral without a single government
regulation telling them to do so
net neutrality types also worried that
companies will charge some users for the
amount of data they use instead of a
flat monthly fee some companies might do
this but it could actually result in
cheaper prices for those users who don't
download several feature-length movies a
day or run a video hosting website after
all someone has to pay for the increased
use of bandwidth just like someone has
to pay for the increased electricity
used by the mansion down the street or
by the local mall yet we pay for our
electricity use as individuals or
households not by subsidizing the use of
everyone in the country and for those
customers who do on a flat monthly fee
competing companies will likely
recognize that desire and offer services
to meet it the same way many of these
same companies offer varied cellphone
plans customized to the user not
designed as a one-size-fits-all standard
by the government but the larger point
is nobody predicted how the internet
would evolve who knows what the internet
could look like in 5-10 years if it's
left free to continue evolving allowing
service providers to continue innovating
freely can only improve the level of
service while clumsy FCC regulation yes
the same FCC that levies massive fines
for nipple slips and fleeting expletives
on live TV will only stunt the
internet's development not to mention it
will give the US government and its many
many lobbyists unprecedented power over
the freest medium of expression still
existing in the world
hmm what could go wrong
you